hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to bad dream butcher now
there's the first part in a six-part
series of Quentin click horror games not
that I know much about it but it's
supposed to be very very good and I'm
interested because of the simplistic
style that it was represented because
looking at the screenshots it doesn't
seem like there was a lot going on but
73 I could read that from where I was
whoa I didn't mean to do that
where's that brick was there a reason
for that breaking okay so it's a
point-and-click style adventure game
which like a lot of the horror games
that I play Oh 73 I know that number I
just read that number I'm smart and
couldn't remember numbers ah I can't
talk right but I can remember lady then
there's a lot of negative space not
being taken advantage of in this game I
don't know if I suppose it means
something or what okay so oh oh oh I got
sharp glass oh I guess I need to put my
face on the bottom but I'm seem to be a
little more bloody than I was before
that's weird weird I guess I don't need
any more glass hi how are you cat pig
did you just bite me you little bastard
take his hammer to your face that's what
I'll do why did you bite me why did I
put my hand towards a cat pig obviously
it was not friendly okay oh I'm missing
a finger what the hell it bit off my
finger okay so I got the key to 33
that's weird
99 great 99 fret luftballoons so let's
not stick my fingers in any unusual
places which is my normal habit oh those
spiders oh those are maggots great I got
one
congratulations me I got a maggot I'm so
happy that I could not have maggots
[Laughter]
okay so that's that 15 this something
weirds going on here something very
strange is happening this is unusual
like it's catching me off guard because
I don't know what I'm doing and I don't
know why I need to do the things that I
need to do is that covered up by human
skin or skin of any sort would be
disturbing also I guess I'm done here hi
buddy can I my finger back you bastard
so I got a key to 33 but not a key to 73
why do I need a sharp glass maggot and a
hammer it seems like illogical things oh
hey here we go hi birdie are you gonna
bite my finger off okay I got a twig
what does a cluck domain e act picking
up everything in anything
excuse me birdy I was talking I don't
even know if that was you but don't
interrupt I can't even like click on the
things in my inventory to try to
interact with anything in the
environment I guess that's for the best
because that means I won't be wasting my
time so I can't go in there
I did get a twig though so that's an
accomplishment I did that I said that
tonight this is weird
can I hear that oh oh there's more oh oh
hi eyeball thing I just oh hey what
how's that a thing oh did he bash it
open try to get out after I stay home
without a shadow of a thing up there
[Music]
high 33
hi oh so many things and questions that
I have but uh I'll stay around here too
long
damn 51 good but what about the door to
15 where is that I don't know so is that
my reflection is that someone standing
in the window there
[Music]
okay alrighty then that's a thing
oh is that you Crillon you look so good
oh wow I'll just be on my way then
okay alright so now I gotta make my way
back to door hi my finger why should I
be upset what the hell was that about
oh oh oh I thought that was an end
that's not I died I'm not doing so good
am I
oh the twig did that if I had done that
with my finger I woulda lost another one
because I've lost two so far and now I'm
giving this super finger a la Dane Cook
ha ha the same cook even do anything
anymore
who knows is there anything else I can
do okay I got the mousetrap oh oh there
was a mouse there was a mouse hole there
was a mouse hole back here no and uh I
saw that I saw that
[Music]
nice the last one I should stop sticking
my hand near things gotcha
take that dead rat I sure got you I
showed you a thing or two and get out of
here before I lose any more okay so what
do I do with a dead rat if I feed it to
the pig
we just fish it out with my one
remaining finger Oh making a fishing out
I got a hook so what am I gonna do with
a hook I supposed to do am I supposed to
know what I'm supposed to do with this
lose my last one I've got no fingers
left on that hand
oh my fingers back BAM
cool key key to what exactly how do I
have any anything left on my hand
I don't know and what was the point of
that why did I need to lose a finger to
do that damn it
okay good I guess we're moving forward
now sticky there I still always took my
thumb oh I still have my ring finger
left that's good I'm glad this is a
happy
I don't know if there's like any way to
actually not lose any of your digits
even though I'm just very bad at this
game here we go I got a fishing rod okay
so now I assembled that with the hook in
the rope or the wire so now that I have
a fishing rod I can do some fishing
I guess so where do I do fishing
I got a maggot - Oh what was that I
[Laughter]
clown look good okay so now that I got a
fishing rod here yeah oh I did something
else okay I got a wet rag great great
for me why why do I have a wet rag why
did I need a wet rag why was a wet rag
the most important thing in my life
hi thank you bye I'm gone thank you I
did not need any of that I don't need
any of your wares from this lovely store
that you have so I got a wet rag so what
about that okay all right okay
oh oh cool I got a pot I can make Dindin
bang bang
dinner everybody escape the name better
with some lunch or dinner cuz I just
said that
okay so I got a full pot now I will do
things with oh it was a stove I know I
know there was a stove I know I need hey
I did it
good let me get some maggots ooh going
up in this baby yeah I'm gonna feed the
hungry and the poor meaning me hey okay
that's the thing all right geez why is
this game so creepy like this is a
really really interesting and creepy
game okay so I gotta find a place is
there like somewhere that I have not
been oh fish
I fished it out of a toilet that's
delightful I'm gonna whip that baby up
and a new student did I did I fish the
dead fish out of that pipe that led from
that toilet to here and also how did I
do that
okay whatever I'm gonna make me some
dead fish new and I'm my own butcher
that's so weird and cool either way this
is the first part in a six-part series
like I said I mean if you guys want to
see it I'm definitely gonna play it but
frankly I kind of want to play it myself
this is really really interesting game I
mean for being a point-and-click and not
saying there's anything wrong with a
point click but it's a genre as old as
like the earliest of games but I mean
this was really really well done it was
well executed there was so many little
surprises hidden throughout the game and
I thought I was doing something horribly
wrong by getting my fingers all chopped
off but maybe it's like I don't think
you needed to get your fingers chopped
off at anyone you could have escaped it
I just didn't know how but that being
said it ended up with a tasty stew my
mom lost so thank you everybody so much
for watching check out the other scary
games that I played in the playlist
down the trip and below or in the
annotation over there there's like 200
of them lots of scary games from years
past so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video no thank you chat all
right back this house a guy playing a
sousaphone in my hair
[Music]